ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es inconsciente
bueno
un día mientras salía de mi trabajo me
encontré a una perrita lastimada
y así literal como que le habían
atropellado con sangre y todo y bien me
tenía que ir lo que hice fue la guardo
aquí y horita regreso para ir a
atenderla
y cuando en cuanto regreso llegó y la
llevo un veterinario la zona donde yo
estaba en una zona cara por la forma
comercial que se movían las cosas y en
eso llegó con el veterinario y voy a
echarme la mano no es mía la perra este
pero no la pude dejar se le dijo no te
preocupes te voy a cobrar nada más la
medicina pero me falta un estudio dije a
ver qué hago no traía dinero andamos
emprendiendo apenas ya saben entonces
pues dije bueno voy a postear por cien y
le puse alguien que tenga este estudio
para una perrita que encontramos
atropellada etcétera etcétera por todos
lados salieron amigos de veterinario y
familiares de veterinarios veterinarios
y rápidamente lo solucionamos y howard
le decía llegó con el estudio y con la
perrita otra vez y linterna lo operan y
empiezan a curarla no
y dicen pues ahora les tanto son dos mil
pesos creo que me dijo hijo lenón os
traigo bueno dadme chance otra vez que
voy pongo un post dije necesito 20
voluntarios de 100 pesos para pagar a la
perrita
y dije y les ponía fotitos y obviamente
los promovía y con la carita de la
perrita nada pues en 20 minutos tómala
jazz tenía el dinero ahí hasta le tuve
que decir ya con eso con eso por favor
porque si me sobra lo como sólo regreso
no y en eso
pues imagínense después de eso es decir
hay que animo a la gente si es buena
no es algo que a lo mejor no lo sabíamos
pero la gente si es buena y en redes en
un mundo donde la gente utiliza las
redes para quejarse la gente es buena y
así pasó me fui a un viaje de trabajo a
la ciudad de méxico y mientras
socialistas ya en la condesa ahí
cotorreando este tú eres de tijuana si
podio bien emocionado tijuana no bien
donde matan ingreso
donde secuestran donde roban y empecé
así como ir tranquilo estamos diciendo a
gusto nunca
entonces se siente que tienes atacado y
medio la verdad pues una sensación pues
muy extraño imagínate yo creo que en
decirlo es que yo vengo de parís yo
vengo de londres no ellos que les van a
decir ahora están aterrice en donde
desde entonces en mi caso pues no a mi
me señalaron y me viene triste ya cuando
llegó dije oye se me olvidó decirle que
los de tijuana me ayudan a salvar a una
perrita son buenos no matan no entonces
ahí me quedé como como atorado y esas
veces que se te olvida y hubiera dicho
esto no es que se te olvida y no y ya
pues en ese momento dije no algo tengo
que hacer nadie estaba haciendo nada
nadie este nos estamos en la agencia
emprendiendo y
nos pusimos pues a crear una plataforma
que se dedicara imagínense van a pensar
que está de locos porque a todo lo que
haremos en las redes de repente es por
las cosas feas decir vamos a hacer una
plataforma donde se hable exclusivamente
bien de tijuana así tal cual y es como
nace yo amo tijuana y comenzamos a subir
cosas y la gente comenzó a reaccionar
imagínense que todos los días
encontramos estamos hablando hace cinco
años que empezó de eso algo bueno que
poner de la ciudad comenzamos a hacer la
voz de la señora de los burritos bien
ricos de la esquina quien nunca iba a
salir un reportaje pero que cuando lo
pusimos explotó e hizo viral y la señora
le faltaban burritos para vender y
fuimos la voz del deportista que se fue
representamos a nivel internacional que
nunca iba a salir en los medios diciendo
este muchacho se fue con sus propios
méritos a capón no y nos hicimos la voz
de ellos y del otro y diario nos
mandaban mucha información de orgullo
tijuanense de ese tipo y comenzó a
crecer imagínense estar un negocio que
suave
qué bonito es tener un negocio donde te
paguen por hablar bien no porque este es
un negocio tan digno saber que estás
siempre las cosas que está subiendo son
por cosas buenas para ti ciudad entonces
comenzamos a crecer a crecer tanto que
evita y ustedes ven una página de
facebook lo que yo veo son 30 personas
sentadas trabajando o paradas o grabando
entonces ya tenemos más de 500 mil
seguidores y hay de entre 3 y 5 millones
de impactos semanales hablando bien de
la ciudad de repente deja mensajes
diciendo quiero ir al lugar que subieron
dónde está el lugar fulano oye me
encantó este lo que recomendaron y
entonces nos dimos cuenta como se hizo
una comunidad donde en vez de que se
empiece a hablar mal de la ciudad se
está hablando bien al menos desde
nuestra trinchera no y eso se nos empezó
a acercar muchas marcas a trabajar con
nosotros y esto literal se convirtió en
un negocio pero un negocio nada más para
nosotros un negocio para esa marca que
le va muy bien
el requisito es haces algo bueno por la
ciudad claro que te promovemos eres un
ace
bueno ahí es diferente te promovemos y
ahí y no necesario
algún pago etcétera depende del proyecto
y comenzamos a generar todo un
ecosistema donde hemos levantado
negocios que ni siquiera que llevan a
quebrar pero que no tenían la
oportunidad de de ellos proyectarse por
y al siguiente día está saturado de
gente conociendo los manjares no
entonces ahí es donde me di cuenta como
lo que verdad lo que en verdad es
tijuana y en el mundo yo puedo apostar
que hay miles de tijuana hay miles de
ciudades que las acusan y las etiquetas
de ser violentas feas malas pero nadie
se ha puesto a decir vengan a ver esta
parte bonita de mi ciudad vengan a
venderla y si no somos nosotros los
ciudadanos los que amamos en nuestra
ciudad los que hablamos las que
presumimos pues nos va a pasar lo que
nos pasó con la ciudad de mexico
diciéndonos es lo único que ven ellos es
lo único que ve lamentablemente el único
que ven y es lo que se creen de la
ciudad no yo invito porque sé que este
este vídeo puede llegar a muchas partes
del mundo yo invito a que los repliquen
se roben la idea lo que quieran decir
agarren sociedad amen la presume la
comiencen a hablar bien de ella levanten
la porque si no lo hacen ustedes nadie
de afuera va a venir a hacerlo de verdad
es una es una idea donde te puedes dar
cuenta que la gente es buena y la gente
quiere ayudar
el único problema es que no saben cómo
hacerlo y nosotros ustedes o quien haga
el proyecto les puede decir cómo hacerlo
definitivamente es una experiencia
hermosa tener a esta página tener este
equipo obviamente no lo hago yo somos
muchísimos trabajando ahí y es un ver es
un lo podría llamar yo como una
bendición tenerlo no
es increíble que lo hagas a través de
gente que es buena la oportunidades las
oportunidades la vida te las pone
enfrente cada ratito pero a veces se
disfrazan de una perrita lastimada yo
soy tony hernández y yo amo tijuana
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]